new this morning Keith Urban is back the
country star hits the stage again at the
back theater Inside Planet Hollywood on
Friday he's known for his guitar Mastery
so who would ever imagine he still gets
a little nervous I had a chance to sit
down with him here's what he told me
about performing
how do you keep the energy alive for you
both as a writer as a musician as a
performer what makes it different each
time
uh because I've never seen that day this
literally every day I mean just it's
every every time I walk on that stage
it's brand new I resisted a residency
because I thought it was going to be the
same thing night after night and it's
not it's just not and it really I
realize it doesn't matter where I'm
playing if I'm touring if I'm in a
residency it doesn't matter that that
first time I've walked on stage that
night in front of that audience it's the
first time that whole combinations
happen so I get
butterflies anxiety excitement the
Euphoria
um nervous since I get everything and I
just can't wait to get out there so you
know that's how that's how I approach
every night
well Sherry said I think we get
butterflies when he's performing as well
he has eight shows through July 1st
there are still some tickets available
and as for new music don't worry fans I
asked he said he's gonna have a single
coming out in the next few months he's
currently finishing up another studio
album